vigilada por el Cristo Redentor y el pan
de azúcar se encuentra la playa de
flamengo una de las imágenes de las
postales de Río de Janeiro
[Música]
Aunque es una Bahía hermosa poco se
aventuran a meterse en sus aguas como
este turista francés
teníamos que empujar un poco la basura
pensábamos darnos un chapuzón pero ahora
cuando necesito refrescar me voy a las
duchas que están un poco más lejos del
agua del mar Pero al menos no hay basura
la Bahía de guanabara se ha convertido
en una de las zonas más contaminadas de
la costa brasileña frente a Río en la
ciudad de niteroy incluso hay un
cementerio de barcos al menos 50 restos
de embarcaciones de todos los tamaños se
encuentran a lo largo de este canal y el
número va en aumento
con su asociación Bahía viva Sergio
Ricardo lleva 40 años denunciando la
contaminación de la Bahía y la inacción
de las autoridades locales como de la
empresa encargada de gestionar el
acueducto y el alcantarillado de Río de
Janeiro privatizada hace dos años y que
había prometido invertir más de 500
millones de euros para limpiar la Bahía
de todos estos barcos ya se ha filtrado
o se sigue filtrando combustible gasoleo
metales pesados sustancias tóxicas
etcétera en el medio ambiente este
cementerio de barcos tiene repercusiones
socioeconómicas sobre la salud pública y
la vida Marina
los restos de las embarcaciones son solo
la punta del iceberg
según un estudio de la universidad
Federal de Río de Janeiro cada segundo
se vierte en 18.000 litros de agua
residuales sin tratar en la Bahía
esta contaminación amenaza la rica
biodiversidad de la Bahía como los
delfines cuya población ha pasado de 200
ejemplares a tan solo unos 30 en pocos
años
cuando se alimentan ingieren partículas
pedazos de residuos sólidos que flotan
en la Bahía y acaban muriendo
y acaba combinando
este equipo de biólogos de la asociación
Guardianes del mar va a los manglares
que bordean la Bahía a los que ellos
llaman la isla de los desechos cientos
de toneladas de basura acumuladas desde
hace décadas
el lecho de los manglares está
completamente cubierto por esta cantidad
de desechos sólidos
vienen a ver los daños de cerca aquí
tenemos basuras tiradas incorrectamente
por ejemplo
alguien que ya no quiere sus sofá o sus
muebles se los tira a la calle Y como
acá llueve mucho sobre todo en esta
época del año las inundaciones arrastran
las basuras hasta los ríos hasta acá y
finalmente hasta el mar
vamos a limpiar toda esta basura
con el barro hasta las rodillas el
biólogo tiene que dar media vuelta en
esta zona de muy difícil acceso donde
las autoridades locales no se atreven a
entrar la asociación no cuenta con apoyo
les llevará 10 meses limpiarlo todo con
pocos recursos hay más de 20 hectáreas
de basura hasta un metro de profundidad
desde 2001 ya han sacado 52 toneladas de
basura una tarea realmente laboriosa
calculamos que cada día cerca de 90
toneladas de residuos sólidos son
arrojados a la Bahía de guanabara estos
pueden descomponerse y entrar en la
cadena alimentaria los peces más
pequeños se comen el plástico y a estos
se los comen los peces más grandes que
acaban en nuestro plato esta
contaminación amenaza también una de las
principales actividades económicas de la
región la pesca artesanal de la que
dependen miles de personas el proyecto
de la ong hace posible que Los
Pescadores que participan en la limpieza
reciban una remuneración Uno de ellos es
Alexandre Ribeiro
Hay días que venimos y no pescamos nada
otros días pescamos
5 kilos
10 kilos
ha habido semanas en las que trabajamos
sin parar y no sacamos ni 10 kilos
la mitad de Los pescadores de su
comunidad han abandonado a la región a
él mismo le resulta cada vez más difícil
mantener a su familia Pero Rendirse no
es una opción
nací crecí aquí soy más joven que muchos
otros
tengo la esperanza de que la situación
vuelva a ser como antes
una esperanza muy pequeña la Bahía de
guanabara ha perdido el 60% de su
superficie original de manglares desde
la época colonial además de ser un
ecosistema esencial y un lugar de
reproducción para muchas especies los
manglares ayudan a filtrar el agua
contaminada Los guardianes del mar ya
han replantado 40 hectáreas
esta replantación permitirá el retorno
de la vegetación característica de los
manglares
en Consecuencia de todos los cangrejos y
otros animales que viven en los
manglares y contribuyen a la mejora
general de este ecosistema
según un estudio económico realizado por
el estado de Río en 2022 la limpieza y
conservación de la Bahía generaría más
de 4 mil millones de euros en 30 años
gracias al turismo principalmente